who wants a drink me please here we go
the deal is this is my last hurray
because I made a New Year's resolution
that I'm not going to drink anymore
during the week this is equal parts
Scotch absent rum gin vermouth Triple
Sec and two packs of Splenda call it on
one of everything
oh my God
hit me again all right one more time
around the block
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right
how do you feel a little better
TMI fire girl
do so yeah okay you know what I thought
we should do is have a quick
intervention and then get back to the
party Michael we're only allowed to talk
about Meredith's work performance we
cannot ask her to stop drinking I am not
asking her to stop drinking I am
imploring her to quit being an alcoholic
I'm I'm not an alcoholic yeah obviously
you are
okay everybody who thinks a Meredith is
an alcoholic please raise your hands all
right the eyes have it I don't care what
everyone thinks
I know I am not an alcoholic right
well
let's look at this a little bit closer
then shall we
when I was in college I used to get a
wicked hammered
my nickname was puke
I would chug a fifth of Soco sneak into
a frat party
off a few people's empties
some brewskis some jello shots do some
body shots off myself
pass out wake up the next morning boot
rally morsoco head to class
probably would have gotten expelled if
it let it affect my grades but I aced
all my courses they called me Ace
it was totally awesome got straight bees
they called me Buzz
Meredith have you ever used alcohol to
alter your mood or deliberately change
your state of mind sure
do you sometimes have a drink to
celebrate a special occasion or Mark a
holiday obviously
have you ever under the influence of
alcohol question the teachings of the
Mormon church
where did you get this I got it on a
website that's not important I always
should contact some experts you don't
know what you're doing hey you know what
Toby one of my employees is undergoing a
crisis and I wish for just once you
would take my side on this
job man
hey are you texting yeah because this is
kind of a drag alcohol is a drag yes
here's what I'd like to do I'd like to
go around the room and have us each
Express to Meredith how her alcoholism
has affected us
I'll begin this Christmas party is
perhaps the best Christmas party I have
ever been to but then you got so drunk
that we had to stop and do this
that's how your drinking affected me
anybody else another time when
Meredith's drinking affected you
come on people if we don't say anything
she's not going to get any better
yes Kevin
well Meredith there was that one time
that you bought movie tickets and then
you got too drunk to go
so you gave them to me and that was
really cool
that's you didn't
you weren't hurt by that yep you said
affected by it thanks again okay no
that's not what we're going for who has
a problem with Meredith's drinking it
has to bother you it bothers me right
how does it bother you Dwight don't you
have anything no I like Meredith
actually I don't care for Meredith but I
don't believe in this kind of thing in
the shrewd family we believe in a
five-fingered intervention awareness
education control acceptance and
punching who's going to tell us the
latest dirty joke who is going to tell
us what you watched on television last I
am fine was John Belushi fine was Bob
Hope fine
hey
if anything ever happened to you
I would be very angry at myself
for not doing all that I could do
I know I drink
I like to party I want you to say I'm an
alcoholic I'm not an alcoholic
say it as loudly as you want but we're
not going to believe you
I was waiting until later to hand out
this year's gifts from corporate
I don't think they're appropriate
anymore
hey Meredith heading over to Poor
Richards yep cool cool
you need a ride
all right let's head out
sounds good do you have a coat
yeah I'll see you at home okay great
okay perfect bye
still don't get why you can't just call
her a cab and pay for it I would it just
that wasn't the holiday wish either he
drives or I drive and now I'm drunk and
mad
okay bye
all right come on there that lie
Santa
let's go let's go let's go okay okay
hang on all right
what is all that my valuables it's just
my treasures
no no no you'll be careful be careful ah
my Santa suits stuck Michael
you ran over me with your car
you posted a picture of my bare boobs on
the bulletin board with a caption that
said Gross well Michael you are the
reason I drink
you are the reason I live to forget
[Applause]
Sunrise rehab no no no I told you no no
there is no it's okay it's all right
Meredith we're doing this for your own
good okay come on here we go this is
this is gonna be good it's gonna be oh
no we talked about this absolutely no
way there we go
no
no no no all right here we go get there
yes you are
[Music]
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute just wait just wait okay
oh my God oh my God
come on no no
there's no way
no no start beating no hello
so
I sign no